this is a production of Cornell
University
so today I'm going to talk about some of
the different types of projects that
I've been involved in in Geneva and this
is going to seem possibly like a
schizophrenic talk and if so that's
because my job is a little bit
schizophrenic
I work in two research units both the
plant genetic resources unit and those
of you who are lucky enough to hear
Joann last week speaks she's in this
unit but I also work with the grape
genetics research unit so this one is
involved in conservation of crops and
it's a seed bank sort of sort of group
and this one is more involved in
understanding grape genomics and
genetics and disease resistance so let's
just start by talking about what is a
computational biologist there's a lot of
terms you hear bioinformatics
computational biology and I like the
term computational biologist because it
explains the fact that I am first a
biologist but I do it by computers so my
original training was in genetics I
think about the structure function and
evolution of genomes but I do it in a
computer instead of at a lab bench or in
the field so that's the perspective that
I come to this with I started as a
biologist and then added the computers
so here's why what I do is going to
sound a little bit complicated and
that's because it is 80% of my time is
paid for by the folks who work in the
clonal repository in clonal just means
that these crops are grafted so that's
the apples the tart cherries and the
grapes that we curate in Geneva and we
distribute the germ plasm and
characterize it and I'm part of the
characterizing process 24% of my time
where is working with the seed
repository and there are many many
vegetables in this report
auditory joanne is in this group and one
of them is tomato and you'll see some
work that we did in tomato they're
together 15 percent of my time is on
Apple rootstock breeding with general
fat CEO who's in this this section and
then the remaining 20% of my time is
split between working on grapes ion
genomics and grape disease resistance so
I work on a vast variety of types of
questions and a vast variety of
organisms and so what you're gonna see
today is going to cover a lot of
organisms and a lot of questions so just
bear with me strap your seatbelt in
because it's going to be fast but what
I'm gonna try and do is least get across
what it is we wanted to find out why we
wanted to find it out and what we found
out but there's a lot of projects so
just bear with me so the first the first
series of projects I'm going to talk
about actually came out of a
collaboration with people in this very
department Courtney and Surin approached
me many years ago and asked me what can
we do with the resistance gene analogs
in rubus and I realized there's an
opportunity here to work out a system
that could be applied to the other crops
that we have in our repository and so we
did that and actually what came out of
that was also eventually later a
master's thesis from a student at RIT so
one of the things I've done in Geneva is
help supervise or act as a functional
thesis advisor for masters students
working in the field of bioinformatics
at Rochester Institute of Technology who
need real-life problems to work on and
somebody to help guide them through that
they can apply what they've learned
toward and then make it into a thesis
and there's two theses I'll talk about
today and one of them was done with
Aubrey Baily so it's kind of neat to see
the progression and one of this project
actually came out of something that was
a collaboration
originally from this department so in
this project we collected a whole bunch
of resistance gene analogues now it's
convenient about these NBS lrr
resistance genes is that they have
conserved fried sections that can be
used for sitting primers down and then
you can amplify between them to get the
variable part and you can all because
that's a convenient thing to do lots of
people have done this in other organisms
besides the ones that we gathered the
sequences from so we gathered a whole
bunch from gene Bank we collected some
from cherry from our collection we
collected a whole bunch from apples in
our collection and there are even the
ones that we got from the project with
Courtney and with these what Aubrey the
student from RIT was able to do was to
cluster these and we were able to see
classify these resistance genes
according to what their sequence
similarity was based on a hypothetically
translated protein sequence so this was
a huge huge huge project and we were
also involving all of the resistance
genes found in the recent been recently
sequenced apple genome so we did a big
tree we found that they were classified
that there were some resistance genes
that were not even found in domestic
apple at all but they were available in
other wild species and that's important
because if you're trying to find parents
to breed for novel resistance an apple
you might want to go for the samples in
our germ plasm collection that have
novel resistance gene analogs so that
that can in turn help breeders and
meanwhile we've also with a big group
that involved collaborators from all
over the world we've mapped some of
these resistance gene analogues to
fire blight resistance hello sigh and
recently we're just finishing up there's
one that might actually it came from a
powdery mildew resistant cherry strain
and Amy Aya's Oni
in Michigan State is mapping QTL there
and so it may be that we'll also have a
similar result that these things are
showing up in the same part of the
genome that is involved in known
resistance for cherries as well so that
was that was one project we're switching
gears now
now here's another type of project I've
done and this one had to do with
figuring out what the risk was of
transferring transmitting resistant
alleles or sorry disease susceptible
alleles depending on which grapefruit
stock you use so there was a question
with this freedom grapefruit stock it's
valuable because it's nematode resistant
but the question about freedom is
doesn't already have is it likely to
already have flux or resistance or not
if it's likely to be flux or susceptible
then it might not be so good for
breeding more grapefruit sucks so the
question in this case was more of a
paternity analysis question because if
we could piece together who the parents
and grandparents were of freedom and if
they were not vanilla then freedom was
more likely to be resistant to phlox
Roth we knew that freedom was derived
from open pollinated parents and there
were 31 potential pollen donors in a
grape in a vineyard in Fresno that David
ramming one usda grape
breeder had but we didn't know which
parents might be the actual pollen
donors so we did took thirty
microsatellite markers and this is old
technology but it
still interesting so we took 30 micro
satellite markers and we looked at this
genetic tree of freedom and also of its
half subharmonic and we started asking
who are the pollen donors and we found
some of them so we knew that and also
some of these individuals were dead so
the ones in the boxes are definitely
dead and we knew that the mother of
freedom was sixteen 1359 we were able to
confirm that because that sample was
still alive in the vineyard when we
tested we knew that the mother for 16
the grandmother was supposed to be 16 13
see we confirmed that and then we
identified that the grandfather of
freedom was a cross derived from a cross
between ripe area and reap estrus
neither of which is vanilla which is
really nice because that means that it's
less likely to be susceptible to falaqa
we also tried to find these individuals
but it appears that they were no longer
alive in the vineyard or else their
alleles weren't unique enough to be able
to identify with this study so that was
a paternity analysis in grape that we
did okay switching gears again here's
another master's thesis this one is on a
completely different organism it's not
even a plant we're talking about fungi
now lance Cadle davidson is a
collaborator of mine in Geneva and he
works on disease resistance in grapes
and in on their pathogens and he had a
project where he had a lot of sequence
from a great many different varieties of
grape powdery mildew and the problem and
he got his thesis this year or just this
past year and he was again another RIT
student that I had supervised first
thesis
and the problem with great powdery
mildew which is here is that there was
almost no information about it there may
be five sequences in GenBank altogether
or something on it it was very very few
and it's next closest relative that we
knew anything about was way down here
bloom area Graham anise now this one was
sequenced and there was a paper where
lots of people got together and
annotated it but there was nothing
available for this organism and so what
we did was we went to transcriptomics so
we took the transcripts and we had to
figure out how to assemble a reference
transcriptome from scratch and then how
to describe the polymorphisms among the
different isolates and we had 56 of them
if you include the reference version so
this was one example of taking organism
that you know almost nothing about from
scratch and figuring out what you can
just from the transcriptome so together
Jason and I worked out a workflow and
this was a lot of trial and error we had
a lot of four or five for sequencing of
the of one single isolate and then we
had a lot of Illumina paradin sequencing
data from that isolate plus 55 other
geographic isolates now what's different
about these isolates is that some
there's a there's a genetics arms race
going on between the powdery mildew and
the grape and the question is what
regions of the powdery mildew genome are
mutating more quickly because if we can
figure out which ones are mutating more
quickly we might have a clue as to which
parts are helping the powdery mildew
gain access foothold into the vineyards
where they're supposed to be
distance so in other words how its
winning its side of the arms race so
that was the whole object so in order to
do that first we had to figure out how
to assemble the genome sorry the
transcriptome so it was assembled it was
mapped to the closest relative and then
we also did paired in sequencing
assembled that and assembled that de
novo out of these three different
assemblies we devised ways of asked to
ascertaining which assembly was the best
one and that's tricky all in itself
because is it by length of context is it
by number of context and or is it maybe
by how many protein sequences are
predicted that makes sense based on what
you expect in say the next closest
relative so you have to balance a lot of
different criteria in order to figure
out which is your best assembly to begin
with now once we did do that then we did
some finer tuning of figuring out which
genes we had relative to what was known
in bloom area gram Onis than nearest
relative and then we took the single end
sequence or the the other isolates and
aligned them as well put this all
together and ended up putting it in a
genome browser so our scientific
colleagues at the bench in other parts
of the country in the world could then
go and identify these regions and start
to focus their research on them so
here's an example of some of the types
of ways that we would visualize the data
in order to figure out if what we had
even made sense over here on the left is
simply a scatter plot of contig length
versus number of reads in the context so
the idea is that you would want to have
bigger contexts ought to be bigger not
because you have the same read piling
up on top of itself over and over and
over but rather you have multiple reeds
all sticking next to each other building
a larger and larger and larger context
and it's sort of comforting to see that
we do have a relationship there where
you have more context or more reeds in
the larger context so that means the
assembly is probably working fairly well
and that the libraries weren't just
copies all of the same transcript over
and over and over and over on top of
each other because even when you
normalize that doesn't always
necessarily work so this was good
confirmation that the assembly seemed to
be working and that the normalization
had worked pretty well and then you want
to ask well if the context as they get
longer and longer then they ought to
match things that you expect to see in
that organism better and better and
better because if you do say a blast
match between two different sequences
the score that you get is dependent on
the length of that match so the longer
the longer that section of sequence is
that matches the better your score is
and so if you have a contig that's
longer it ought to have better potential
to match a long context somewhere else
in other words it ought to have a better
blast score and so here is a graph with
the context along the x-axis so the
longer contexts are over here and the
shorter contexts are here and here is
the blast score and you can see that
well we do get some longer contigs with
pretty low blast matches the best blast
matches do come from the longest context
and that makes sense so that means that
these are probably matching what what
they should so not only did the Assembly
assemble thing
and in the end the way that should have
but the things that assembled actually
are matching stuff that we expect to see
and this is all the sort of work that
you have to go through when you've got a
brand new organism nobody knows anything
about Jason did a lot of work for this
he did a good job so let's just take a
look at how much did we see versus what
we expected to see now one of the ways
that we did our annotation the way we
labeled what we found in the powdery
mildew genome was we did reciprocal
blasts so we searched the powdery mildew
genome with the bloom area gram Onis
transcripts or protein sequences and
then we searched the bloom area grameena
sequences with the powdery mildew
sequences and whenever there was a
reciprocal one-to-one match so protein a
liked protein bloom area protein a liked
powdery mildew protein be better than
any other powdery mildew protein and
powdery mildew protein be like bloom
area protein a better than any other
bloom area protein that's what we call a
reciprocal one to one best match and
that's just one quick and dirty way to
figure out whether those two things are
most likely to be the analogs of each
other in each genome and so of when we
did this we found four thousand or 4,500
reciprocal best matches in the bloom
area genome altogether we had only six
thousand queries so that means if flute
if powdery mildew how's about the same
genome size and about the same number of
proteins in its transcriptome as bloom
area then we found over two-thirds of
them and that's pretty good
and they're not the closest relatives in
the world I mean when you saw that tree
there's a lot of things in between and
fungi and you take quick so it's not bad
it's I mean for for the next closest
relative and that was how we labeled the
genes or the proteins that we found in
powdery mildew
now we also characterized these these
proteins among the all the different 56
isolates so we took our what we had over
sequenced our reference isolate and then
compared all the other 55 isolates to it
and some of these like this one and this
one and this one had and dis purports
are artifacts these are not these these
numbers of snips and in Dells are not
because of biological fact but because
these are actually pooled samples
themselves so these samples here
actually represent multiple isolates and
that was an artifact of how this the
laboratory work was done in the
beginning before we figured out how to
properly barcode samples but the other
ones did have numerous snips and indels
and the breakdown was sort of
interesting about of all the predicted
protein differences about 21 percent
were nonsynonymous of those 21 percent
or 18 percent of the total were
nonsynonymous and three percent actually
looked like stop codons now these are
all obviously based on low quality
Illumina tie high-throughput sequencing
error and there's also the fact that
we're conceptually translating these to
begin with as well as comparing them to
their nearest relative protein sequence
and in another organism that who knows
how close it really really is but it's
our best chance so that's all we've got
but all together what we can say is that
the regions where we found so 18 or 20
percent of those polymorphisms do look
like they might be involved in this arms
race between the pathogen and the host
and so those are now the ones that
here's the genome browser and here are
the genes and you can see the various
positions where there are mutations and
these are now the regions of the genome
that our bench colleagues can focus on
to find possible genes related in over
in what powdery mildew uses to overcome
the resistance of the host to its
infection so that was that was a fun
project okay now we're going to move
back into plants and I was one of the
people early on a few years ago who
started looking at how to do along with
Paula here but in a different set of
grape species or great populations how
to use genotyping by sequencing data to
get information about genes responsible
for traits and so one of the projects I
did was I compared the tassel pipeline
which is pure genome-wide Association
mapping and traditional QTL mapping just
to see what would work and the
population I used in this case segregate
it was two populations actually y1 by y3
so the blue versus the red and then y1
versus Y four so the blue versus the
green and so for various traits that had
to do with table grape quality
so in other words less seeds or no seeds
Barry sighs that sort of thing which is
all what you care about is you want a
big berry with no seeds in it or at
least that's what the public wants so
that's what David ramming Lots because
he's breeding table grapes and so our
populations had 71 offspring between
these two individuals and 17 offspring
between these two individuals we
genotyped these two individuals three
times each and this individual twice and
that becomes important later when when
you try to do QTL mapping you need in
order to create a genetic map you really
do if you're doing GBS you really do
need to get deeper coverage of the
parents so let's just talk real briefly
about genotyping by sequencing probably
most of you here have seen this a
million times some of you have even
displayed this slide before yourself
I've seen you do it at PEG but I
borrowed the slide from the workshops
that the Institute of genomic diversity
provides and that's because it's a good
slide basically genotyping by sequencing
is a way of getting polymorphism out of
a genome with just using restriction
enzyme fragments and high-throughput
technology I'm not going to go into a
whole lot more detail about it right now
but basically what you need to know is
we do genome complexity reduction by
choosing the restriction enzyme so in
other words the way we pick where the
genotyping is going to occur is by what
the restriction enzyme site is going to
be the cuts and then we use that
information to figure out where the
polymorphisms are and figure out the
yeah figure out the polymorphism so
you're doing marker discovery and
genotyping simultaneously the advantage
of this over chips if you haven't heard
this already is if you have a snip chip
you have to already know what the
diverse
you expect or what the polymorphisms you
expect to see are going to be otherwise
you won't see them because you're not
asking for them this way if it's there
in a restriction site and you cover the
genome deeply enough you will see it and
so you can either have a loss of a site
which is a lot harder to see because
this day these data are very patchy or
what you can have is a difference in
sequence between two sites and that's
much much easier to ascertain just as a
side note I tried to do a project for
somebody once where sample2 was
gamma-irradiated so they were big
they're supposed to be deletions and the
other genome and it completely failed
with GBS so it if you're thinking of
trying to find deletions by GBS talk to
me first because there's a lot of issues
and and we've it a really hard good
solid try and I wasn't able to do that
so I would not actually consider it very
good at finding deletions but it is good
at finding polymorphisms when the site
is found between multiple organisms so
it's pretty cheap it scales well it
there's no ascertain 'men bias and then
lab wise is nice because you don't have
to size fractionate the way you would
have to do with rad tags which is
another way of doing this sort of data
gathering and you can pick your
restriction enzyme based on how
frequently it cuts and whether or not
it's methylation sensitive and so on so
if you're trying to avoid certain parts
of the genome that might be methylated
say you want to go for the euchromatin
I'm probably dating myself using that
term right if you want to go for the
parts of the genome that have the genes
in them versus the non-coding part of
the genome you might want to go for
methylation sensitive enzymes or
something like that so that's what's
nice about that and so you can pick how
often you get a marker and so on so
let's go back to these two great
populations called and mapped genotypes
there are 19 chromosomes in grape with
the QTL analysis
there were many fewer markers called for
each chromosome and we could we
obviously were able to map them because
we're using join map to map these things
with tassel which was a G wasp method we
used all of the tax and not so for for
these work this for this version we used
just the biggest mapping population the
71 offspring for the G us we're able to
throw all the data in and genetic
mapping wasn't done we just tried to
assume where the markers fell based on
the grape genome sequence that's been
published now that's also problematic
because we know that some of these
markers that when we did our mapping
with join map that those markers did not
show up where the grape genome assembly
said they work so when you use this type
of method you have to watch out for that
sort of thing but the bottom line was
that no matter which method you used it
often found the same region of the
genome so the seedless nough snowin
seedless no skewed seed less this QTL on
linkage group 18 was found both with
tassel which are the green dots and with
map QTL which are the blue dots so if
you have enough data and the data and
the system is robust enough you will
find your your associations either way
so just to summarize the difference
between these two methods if you're
doing traditional mapping you'll get
about ten times less markers because you
need to be confident in how they are
phased between the two parents it
requires a high depth high read depth
for the parents so remember I said we G
know typed y1 + y3 each three times and
if we had not done that we would have
had problems doing traditional mapping
and there was another project that was
trying to do the same thing with a
different population in grape and Palo
remembers and that was tricky because
those parents and only been genotyped
once so I tried running that dataset
through my pipeline and I was not able
to get a genetic map because I didn't
have enough information for what the
markers should be according to what the
parents were because we didn't parents
weren't sequence deeply enough and with
the traditional mapping approach you can
create the map you don't have to you
don't have to have an existing map or
assembly with G wasps you got a lot more
markers and it's a it's a brute-force
method more it uses just the sheer
number of markers to work and it allows
imputation this one this method we did
not do imputed in this method you can
genotype parents once and that might be
good if you had say a big open
pollinated population out in nature and
you're just trying to find out how the
traits were associated in that or if you
had a population that you inherited from
another breeder
and you weren't really sure how the
individuals were related because you
couldn't find their notebooks or
something like that but it was a
valuable enough population of spend time
on because it had the trait you wanted
so G who else would probably be better
for that now it turns out that the
Vettes gen project is actually working
on a way to do mapping genetic mapping
from the
data without having to go through some
of this process and I'm really excited
to see how their unique pipeline will
work and some of the projects I'm gonna
be that I'm working on at the present so
stay tuned and I'll let you know how
that works out okay we're gonna switch
gears again but this time only to a
different great population and I just
want to show you this is one of those
slides that I had to make purposely
vague because I know this is going to
end up on YouTube we have mapped a great
trait a developmental trait to one of
the chromosomes with really strong QTL
evidence using this same technology
where we take the GBS data we filter it
down and then we do traditional genetic
mapping and QTL mapping with it and this
population is beautiful it's got 142
offspring which is huge for a clonal
crop it's great we ended up with a
little over 2,000 markers on a paternal
map because the trait is segregating
between in the in the father and we got
a decent number of markers in each of
the linkage groups about a hundred or so
and so here's here's a trait and
hopefully by this time next year I'll be
able to tell you what it is
openly because we'll publish it okay
finally one other thing I thought would
be fun to tell you about is sometimes
when I'm doing the type of work I'm
doing there aren't tools to do what I
want to do and so part of my job
sometimes not so often most of the time
because most of the time there are other
research labs out in the world doing
what the same kind of thing and I can
take their tool and use it for our
purposes but sometimes there isn't a
tool like that or I don't know about one
or I think of one and then I make it so
I just thought I'd mention this one to
you guys just for fun so in this tool it
was a it was a it was came out an idea I
got from attending Carl severs course so
any
here who hasn't attended or thought
about attending Carl Siebert's
chemometrics course ought to think about
it especially if you ever spend time in
Geneva because it's not just about wine
and beer characteristics it's about how
to do multi-dimensional analysis and I
am not trained in statistics I'm a
geneticist you know I was training like
molecular genetics and a little bit I
had to teach classical genetics when I
was at was on as a grad student but
statistics is not something I'm that
strong in and so I really enjoyed taking
Carl sieverts course in Geneva and one
of the methods that he taught us about
was how to do principal components
analysis and I started thinking about
this and I thought you know genetically
if you have two homozygotes and a hair a
zygote between them from a genetic
perspective the heterozygote is actually
genetically intermediate right if the
traits are codominant so why not do
Pease code those those genotypes as ones
and zeros and twos and treat it like PCA
and see if you get correlations between
the genotype and a treat or a behavior
or some kind of characteristic that
you're interested in so we tried it and
it works and what's really cool about it
is that it's a way to assess genetic
correlation between the markers and the
characteristics because you can get a
principal components loading plot so you
can actually say okay which principle
coordinate actually separates my sample
according to say fruit size or something
and if and if and if one of them does
and the bigger fruits are over here and
the littler fruits are over here
according to that one principal
coordinate then you can actually take
this the data and go back and ask which
markers contributed to that principal
component which which ones are actually
giving which genotype
which alleles are giving you that axis
and that tells you what part of the
genome might be involved so it's a kind
of a cool thing to do the other thing
that's nice about it and the examples
I'll show you here are from this
application and that is it's a direct
way to visualize genetic relationships
among organisms because you can just
plot them according to their principal
components genetically and this
different the spacing you see is the
genetic spacing it's the actual like
amalgam of or addition of all the
different genetic markers and it's so
it's not multi-dimensional scaling where
it's just taking all the data and trying
to like figure out a way to stretch it
out no these are the actual physical
points in space triangular you know
triangulated points in space that you
get when you'd look at genetic the the
some of the genetic differences among
these organisms according to these
different components that separate them
so this has been published and the
example in the paper is tomato data so I
promised tomato data here it is in our
collection in Geneva that Larry
Robertson curates we have samples of
tomato DNA it will samples a tomato
which obviously contain the DNA see
that's where I'm a geneticist because
I'm like we have samples of tomato DNA
in the actual tomato plants yeah and the
question is can we genetically tell
which samples are closer to the origin
of domestication so let me see if I
still have this slide here and
no I don't okay so let me explain what
happened here with tomatoes those of you
who saw Joanne's
talk last week saw a really nice cartoon
of this but basically tomatoes were
domesticated in three general Eric parts
or three place that overlaps with Chile
Ecuador and Peru so this little spot in
South America that's where all the wild
tomato diversity is that's where people
came and said oh we could eat these tiny
little things and then they started like
eating them and somehow in the dark
history of tomato they started becoming
domesticated and eventually the better
ones started spreading and so we have
samples from Chile Ecuador and Peru we
also have samples from the countries
contiguous to them and then what
happened was the conquistadors came from
Europe to South America and said oh what
are these things you people are eating
let us take them back so they took them
to Europe and that was a bottleneck in
in the jeanna in the diversity of
tomatoes so only a subset of the
tomatoes got to go and visit Europe and
then when people from Europe started
colonizing North America they brought
some tomatoes from Europe up to North
America so there have been two major
bottlenecks in the history of tomato
that led to the germ plasm that we have
here now subsequently there's been other
things like int regressions from other
wild species back in that started in the
1940s but before 1940 if you saw tomato
it was usually most diverse if it was
from where tomatoes were domesticated a
little less allelic diversity in the
sample in Europe and then even less in
North America and that was the
conventional wisdom and the question was
could we see this in the tomatoes and
our collections so we looked at
50 different accessions 14 were from
Chile Ecuador and Peru six were from
countries next to Chile Ecuador and Peru
and 30 were from places other than that
like other continents and sure enough
first of all it's kind of interesting
the first principal component explained
20% of the variation in the data in the
genetic data the second principal
component explained 10% more and the
third explained six percent more so only
probably I mean you don't really need to
look deeper than three unless you wanted
to say compare fruit size or something
like that and maybe one of the
components later than that might explain
the specific kind of variation you're
interested in but if you're looking at
just the diversity among the samples and
not looking for certain traits traits
diversity in a certain trait then this
is probably good enough just to stop in
the first three and sure enough the
biggest cloud are these yellow dots
these represent the 14 samples from the
primary center of diversity and the red
dots are a little bit less inside of
that cloud they're subsets of that cloud
those are the ones that made it to
places like Argentina where they're
contiguous to Chile say but not in the
in the center of diversity or where they
were domesticated originally and finally
when you look at the last few which is
the last 30 it's hard to see in this
picture but actually that is you can
actually rotate these plots if you use R
which is a really nice staff package
that's free you can see that the blue
dots are actually inside of the yellow
dots and actually smaller than this big
red disc and so actually it worked and
you can actually see that the tomatoes
that come from the places furthest from
where they were originally domesticated
have the least
diversity this method also works in
grapes we did a big study where we
looked at a hundred and twenty
accessions of grapes both in our
collection and some from China that were
brought by our collaborator and we asked
how do these things look if you sequence
30 different genes and you throw their
their sequences into this PCA thing what
does it look like well here are the
first three principal components and the
North American grapes are in this pale
blue color the european grapes are in
this sort of orange color and the asian
grapes are in the blue color and there
are a few that are known hybrids that
are other colors and again what's really
interesting to see is that some of the
North American grapes that come from the
part of North America near Asia are a
little more like the Asian grapes kind
of interesting and we were also able to
show with this we were able to see in
some cases where things that were
labeled as North American were probably
hybrids with vanilla like this one here
so it's a it's a it's a fun it's it's
fun sometimes to develop your own tools
to answer questions about what you're
seeing in the data and this project is
being written up by Heidi schwa Nagar
and a team of us in Geneva actually it's
been written up and it's since we're in
the pools of submitting and resubmitting
at the moment so that's a fun fun thing
too so looks like I'm going to leave
enough time for students to ask
questions which will be nice we have
some other projects in the works just
big ones I've just started surveying
apple germ plasm for srna's alleles and
this is coming out of a project that was
spearheaded by Gallo and Zhang
and Shawn miles that you may remember
from working with Edie buckler on a
grape snip diversity and what they're
doing is or what we've all as a group
done and this also involves
collaborators in Fort Collins too we've
taken 42 species and 1600 accessions
from our collection as well as some
other doméstica proprietary doméstica
varieties that we don't have art
collection and done a huge gb/s survey
of them and two enzymes were used
remember I mentioned that in GPS you can
use different enzymes you can also
combine enzymes to get different
coverage of the genome and of that data
what Shawn and his team are doing are
looking at the diversity among the apple
germ plasm but because these data
involves small snippets of sequence it's
also possible to hunt in them for genes
of interest known genes of interest and
so one thing that I'm doing with Gennaro
Fazio is hunting for markers in the
region of the S RNAs alleles and I guess
I should explain what the srna's alleles
are and why this is important Apple is
self incompatible so if you want to make
an apple that breeds true the only way
to do that is to graft it that's why it
is a clonal crop okay now the many of
you may already know this but in case
you didn't now you do if you want to
breed one Apple to another it has to
have a different s RNA Salil and that's
why for example when you grow an apple
orchard you need to have other than
something say you have a big bunch of
big big bunch of Golden Delicious trees
and you want Golden Delicious apples
well if you don't include at least one
crabapple or some other non Golden
Delicious pollinator you will not get
apples at all okay is that clear
great
all right so also suppose you want to
make apple germ plasm or breed apples
you don't just want to grow them you
want to breed them well you need to know
what the resistance alleles are right so
what we're hoping is that once we survey
our collection for all these different
possible alleles that we may be able to
suggest good alternative breeding
parents for creating new varieties and I
see some of the people who work on Apple
reading nodding so I'm on track and I'm
glad they agree so anyway that's that's
one project that we're doing will also
hunt because I still have those friends
remember way back when I talked about
the RDAs and the fire blight resistance
well those those colleagues down there
and West Virginia are also interested in
disease resistance genes still so once
we've figured out how to survey these
GBS markers for srna's alleles will
branch off into other things and one
might be fire blight resistance and
there may be say dwarfing traits or
other interesting traits that we want in
apples and we'll hunt for them because
it's a nice big database and then we'll
be able to suggest parents another
project that's started is Lance Cal
Davidson has a person that he's hired
for hired into his lab who wants a
master's degree in bioinformatics so
she's actually now in this case instead
of RIT giving us a student we're
actually giving RIT a student but it's
still going to work in the similar way
she's enrolling an RIT in bioinformatics
and Lance and I will work together with
our colleagues at RIT to mentor her
through that process and she's working
on the pathogen botrytis cinerea
so there's some there's some fun other
research projects going on and just
briefly because I know that in the
guidelines for for what we are supposed
to talk about
these adjunct appointments I just
thought I'd mention that I also do a lot
of outreach so I travel to career fairs
and I've given guest lectures in high
schools and like in truman's Brook high
school I have a friend who teaches
biology ap biology and so I've given
crop domestication lectures there we
helped with making DNA with kids and so
there's a lot of fun outreach things
that we get to do with this kind of type
of job too we go to Empire Farm days
talk to the public about the kinds of
work that we do in Geneva and so on so
there are way way way too many collab
individual collaborators to mention so
instead what I'll do is I'll just
quickly mention the labs that I've
collaborated with in Geneva in the USDA
that's every other scientist in the unit
basically and some sadly are no longer
in the group but I've enjoyed working
with them
there are used USDA scientists elsewhere
that I have worked with and still work
with there are Cornell scientists I've
published with and I'm happy if any of
you have any kind of idea for a project
that would relate to our germ plasm or
our grape tsiyon or disease resistance
work let me know or if you have a
student that you want help
guiding because they have some
bioinformatic component let me know I'd
be happy to talk to you
there's also scientists elsewhere
there's Amy Ione Michael Malinois David
Francis sue Gardner Andrews pile marks
Alton ancien lon and finally there were
two RIT students that did masters theses
they came in as summer students liked
working with us so much that they
decided to stay and make their project
based on their their thesis project
based on what we worked on so that's it
thank you so much for your attention and
I'd love to answer questions
okay so the question was whether this
this dataset looked like it matched the
gene flow and the the answer is that
except for these none of these are
developed lines these are Venice
vinifera ants and their wild relatives
and the rest of these are all basically
wild accessions and so nobody really
knows how grapes evolved the problem is
that there looks like there was one big
giant explosion of grapes all at once
and so that's part of the problem with
visualizing these data with a
phylogenetic tree is because what you
get is a big rush of everything off
splitting off almost at once the other
thing that's tricky is that almost all
of these freely in a breed with each
other so as soon as you move one
somewhere else they just start happily
interbreeding there's only one grape in
North America and that doesn't do that
because it has a slightly different
number of chromosomes and and even it
can be made to crossbreed and some
people think it doesn't even belong in
Vitus necessarily or they think it's
like a an out-group so so it does match
what we might expect but it's really
hard to know what to expect given that
none of the trees and none of the
history of grape as a species or a genus
is clear thanks Dave yeah
I don't know if they I'm not sure
they've taken that data I think that
that project came from a snip data
project and remember I said that gb/s
was better than snip chips because
there's no ascertain 'men bias the
problem the reason snip chips are bad
for some organisms is because if you
have a highly outcrossing clonal crop so
this thing is not an annual and it's
highly out crossing you have so much
hetero zygosity expected and so much
diversity that if you use chip
technology to assay a collection you're
going to miss all of the diversity that
wasn't in the original samples that were
used to design the chip and so even if
it I I can't really say because it was
not exactly the same codes collections
first of all and are the same samples
but even if it were its we were directly
sequencing with PCR so if we found a
verse if there was diversity we found it
and they were they used a different
technology and so I'm not sure that what
they found would have been
representative but then on the other
hand they were surveying more of the
genome whereas we are only surveying 30
so it's hard to it's hard to compare
those but but as far as the conventional
understanding of how grapes evolved in
general I would say this is pretty
accurate maybe we didn't expect to
separate lumps of North Americans I
think that might have been unexpected
and definitely as far as identifying
hybrids and mislabeled accessions this
works too this corroborate that sort of
thing yeah
yeah go ahead Oh for the powdery mildew
sure
oops yes we did try to do that but the
computers we had access to were not
powerful enough and this guy needed to
get out he was only working on a
master's so we only had him for a year
we couldn't keep it stuck keep nope nope
sorry you have to stay here for three
more years so if if we had had access to
more powerful computers and more time I
think a hybrid assembly would have
worked but unfortunately it didn't
because of Technology thanks for the
question yes we have an estimate and I
cannot remember what the number is but I
can look it up for you if you're
interested
I believe it's pre-human
it's probably pre-human but you know
what I will look it up and I will get
back to you on that yes
yes
the North American and Asian oops sorry
wrong way okay they aren't as distinct
as they look because if you rotate this
thing you'll see that these fall in the
same plane and if you're interested I
can show you a rotated version of this
sometime it's really fun you just take
your mouse and you grab it and you can
like rotate the whole thing around which
makes it a lot easier to see but harder
to Polycom so I went with a still slide
for this but yeah it's sort of like
these are in one plane and then these
make another sort of when you when you
rotate it it sort of looks like this if
that's
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu